now to the newest effort to restrict
abortion rights in this country
anticipating that the supreme court will
clear the way by overturning its
historic roe v wade decision
oklahoma's legislature approved new
limits yesterday and governor kevin
stitt appears ready to sign this bill
jan crawford covers the supreme court
jan good morning to you what's going on
here well i mean gail oklahoma is really
making a statement i mean if it's up to
some lawmakers there won't be any
abortions in the state and it looks like
they could well make that happen i mean
the bill that passed yesterday bans
abortions after cardiac activity is
detected which is usually around six
weeks but in addition lawmakers also are
on the way to approving another new law
that would ban all abortions except for
rape incest and medical emergencies and
both would allow private citizens to sue
abortion providers for ten thousand
dollar rewards they're modeled after a
texas law that bans abortion after a
fetal heartbeat is detected and gives
private citizens the right to enforce it
now that texas law is in place while
challenges work their way through the
courts this oklahoma law would be the
same and the governor said he would sign
any anti-abortion bill that the
legislature sends them and once signed i
mean these laws would take effect
immediately so that would not only
restrict abortion access for women in
oklahoma but for those texas women
who've been driving to the state for
procedures but yeah i mean it is
important to point out oklahoma is not
alone i mean there are a growing number
of states that are passing these
restrictive abortion laws some would
take effect immediately others would
take effect if the court overturns roe
and we expect that decision by the end
of june
tony all right jan thank you very much